à tout prix l'épidémie de comics 19 sur
notre territoire
ces mesures sont fortes ces volontaires
elles sont exigeantes
nous le savons mais ces mesures sont
nécessaires surtout essentiel pour
protéger toutes les françaises et tous
les français pas seulement les personnes
les plus âgées est essentielle pour
bloquer la propagation de ce virus pour
éviter à tout prix la surcharge de notre
système de santé essentiels pour
combattre le coville 19 et limiter au
maximum le nombre de ses victimes
les mesures annoncées par le président
de la république jeudi puis par le
premier ministre samedi et est d'ores et
déjà des étapes majeures
je tiens à mon tour a salué toutes
celles et tous ceux qui par esprit de
responsabilité ont pris leurs
dispositions ont pris la mesure de la
situation
cependant le constat est lourd mais il
s'impose
la progression du coc vide 19 continue
et trop de personnes font encore peu de
cas des consignes sanitaires données il
n'ya pourtant aucun panache à ne pas
appliquer les gestes barrière aucune
gloire à se refuser aux mesures
sanitaires demandée est de venir
de par son comportement un allié du
virus un danger pour soi un danger pour
les autres aussi dès demain midi pour
une durée de quinze jours qui pourrait
être prolongé des mesures de restriction
ferme des déplacements ont été prises le
mot d'ordre est clair
restez chez vous il s'agit de mesures de
confinement sur le modèle de ce que nos
voisins espagnols ou italiens en mise en
place ce que le président de la
république a décrit ce sont les mesures
les plus restrictives aujourd'hui en
vigueur
europe nous menons un combat nous le
ferons respecter
toutefois l'activité de notre pays ne
doit pas s'arrêter totalement d
exception pourront être toléré pour les
déplacements entre le domicile et le
lieu de travail lorsque ces déplacements
sont indispensables pour des activités
ne pouvons être interrompue ni organisé
sous forme de télétravail pour les
déplacements nécessaires pour faire des
courses ou pour les besoins de première
nécessité je pense aux aliments au
premier aux produits de première es jiel
pour les déplacements pour motifs de
santé bien sûr pour les déplacements
pour motif familial un père lieu où pour
l'assistance de personnes vulnérables
pour venir en aide à un proche dépendant
par exemple ou pour des parents séparés
pour aller chercher et déposer les
enfants d'autres exceptions pourront
être permise pour des déplacements bref
à proximité des domiciles
on croit toujours pratiquer une activité
physique ou sortir son chien mais chaque
devra le faire avec parcimonie dont le
respect des consignes sanitaires et des
gestes barrières sans se retrouver en
groupe
si je devais le résumer je dirais que
l'on pourra prendre l'air oui mais
certainement pas joué un match de foot
dans tous les cas la consigne générale
est simple c'est rester chez vous alors
je ne l'ignorent pas cette consigne
c'est renoncer au déplacement
touristique et qui à bien des loisirs
c'est renoncer à voir ses amis c'est
renoncer au déjeuner ou au dîner en
famille c'est renoncer aux activités
associatives lorsqu'elle ne contribue
pas à des missions d'assistance aller
pique-niquer dans un pack ou dans un
square
c'est interdit se retrouver en groupe
pour jouer c'est interdit ce sont autant
de sacrifices mais je crois qu'on peut
tous les comprendre et les faire quand
il s'agit au fond de sauver des vies y
compris la vôtre comme celle de vos
proches un dispositif de contrôle sera
mise en place par les forces de l'ordre
il reposera sur des contrôles et des
points de contrôle fixes mais aussi des
points de contrôles mobiles à la fois
sur les axes principaux mais aussi sur
les axes secondaires
partout sur le territoire national il
mobilisera plus de cent mille policiers
et gendarmes dès ce soir je donne ordre
aux forces de sécurité intérieure de se
déployer sur le terrain et de préparer
la mise en place des contrôles
toutes les personnes qui circuleront
devons être en mesure de justifier leurs
déplacements cela concerne évidemment
aussi les piétons
pour y parvenir chaque personne pour
chaque déplacement devra se munir d'un
document attestant sur l'honneur le
motif de son déplacement
cette installation sera obligatoire elle
sera téléchargeable en ligne dans la
nuit sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur est progressivement sur
l'ensemble des sites publics et bien au
delà je le souhaite
il appartiendra à chacun de le remplir
pour préciser la nature de son
déplacement
sa destination et ses raisons ceux qui
disposent de quatre professionnels ou de
certificats de leurs employeurs pourront
être amenés à les présenter lors des
contrôles la carte pourront aussi servir
lieu d'attestation ce sera notamment le
cas par exemple des cartes de presse car
l'information jouera un rôle essentiel
aussi dans le combat contre le virus
enfin cette association pourra être
également réalisée sur papier libre
pour ceux qui ne disposent pas d'une
imprimante ou d'un accès à internet
la violation de ces règles est
actuellement puni d'une amende de
l'ordre de 38 euros
elle sera portée très rapidement à un
niveau supérieur qui pourrait être 235
euros
notre objectif n'est pas de sanctionner
mais d'en appeler à la responsabilité de
tous notre objectif n'est pas de
sanctionner mais de montrer un civisme
collectif pour surmonter la crise notre
objectif n'est pas de sanctionner mais
s'il le faut nous le ferons
mesdames et messieurs
cette épidémie vous le savez intervient
alors même que la république travers ce
moment démocratique importante
les élections municipales jeudi dernier
après la consultation des différentes
forces politiques et les autorités
médicales
le président de la république avait
annoncé le maintien du premier tour des
élections municipales et communautaires
je les dis hier soir le premier tour
s'est déroulé dans de bonnes conditions
les électeurs on est accueilli dans tous
les bureaux de vote du pays dans des
conditions d'organisation particulière
respectant les recommandations
sanitaires émise le premier tour a
permis d'élire les conseillers
municipaux de plus de 30 mille de nos
communes ce qui représente environ 65%
des 43 millions d'électeurs que quand
notre pays
l'organisation remarquable mise en place
et je veux ici à nouveau salué la
rigueur et l'engagement des maires élus
candidats et fonctionnaires qui ont
contribué à cette réussite mais aussi le
civisme des électeurs et cela va
permettre qu'à la fin de cette semaine
les conseils municipaux puissent
désigner 30000 mère dans notre pays
les élections qui ont été conclusive à
l'issue du premier tour sont acquises
nul ne comprendrait en effet que les
résultats réguliers d'élections
organisées conformément aux lois de la
république et qui ont permis de pourvoir
à l'issue du premier tour
les conseils municipaux soit remise en
cause c'est l'expression de la volonté
du peuple
c'est le respect aussi que nous devons
au suffrage universel
toutefois pour environ 5000 communes
les résultats du premier tour exige
l'organisation d'un second tour de
scrutin pour cette commune
un second tour sera organisé il doit
l'être et il le sera
le président de la république a indiqué
tout à l'heure que les expertises
scientifiques sollicité conduisent à
reporter l'organisation du second tour
dans les 5000 communes où sa tenue est
nécessaire il a consulté ce jour les
présidents des assemblées le premier
ministre a également consulté les
représentants des forces politiques du
pays et il est apparu qu'elle consensus
existait sur la nécessité de reporter le
second tour de l'élection municipale
cela sur ce double fondement à la fois
l'expertisé médicale d'une part et le
consensus politique d'autre part deux
textes seront pris ils permettront de
tenir compte de la conduite de l'as des
circonstances sanitaire exceptionnelle
que nous vivons et organiseront le
report du second tour des élections
municipales et communautaires dans les
communes où il devait se tenir un décret
pris en conseil des ministres dès demain
abrogera la convocation des électeurs
pour le second tour des élections
municipales et communautaires qui était
prévu samedi 22 mars un projet de loi
qui sera examiné lui aussi dès demain
mais par le conseil d'état et mercredi
par le conseil des ministres organisera
le report de ce scrutin à une date
ultérieure au plus tard au mois de juin
ce projet de loi prévoira que dans un
délai de six semaines au plus c'est à
dire dans le courant du mois de mai un
rapport du conseil scientifique créée
pour la gestion de la crise sanitaire du
cornet virus statuera sur la possibilité
au plan sanitaire d'organiser les
élections un horizon de six semaines
c'est à dire à compter de la mi juin
évidemment nous présenterons ce rapport
d expertise à l'ensemble des forces
politiques de notre pays espéraient
quelques nous prendrons la décision
précise du choix de maintenir et de
joies de la date qui est possible d'ici
la fin du mois de juin
nous déterminerons précisément cela avec
l'ensemble des partis politiques
les géants de demain soir 18 heures ne
s'applique donc pas celle qui fait que
les candidats qui veulent concourir pour
le second tour présentent leur
candidature
le délai donc pour déposer les
candidatures sera repoussée par le
projet de l'eau concrètement pour
organiser le second tour
le projet de loi comprendra plusieurs
mesures fortes
il confirmera que les conseillers
municipaux communautaires élu dès le
premier tour entre en fonction
immédiatement pour les communes où le
premier tour n'a pas été conclusif le
projet de loi prévoit vrac le mandat des
conseillers municipaux et des mères sera
prolongée par la loi
donc nécessaire les maires et les
conseils municipaux en place admise
qu'auront les communes jusqu'à ce que le
second tour soit tenue dans les
communautés de communes communautés
d'agglomération métropole ces
intercommunalités qui organise bien
souvent les services publics essentiels
à la population nous prévoirons un
régime spécifique répondant au caractère
exceptionnel de notre situation ce
régime vers à coexister dans une période
limitée dans une même intercommunalité à
la fois les nouveaux élus dont
l'élection était acquise au 1er tour
ainsi que les élus dont le mandat aurait
été prolongée il sera proposé et
organisé dans ces collectivités
une élection d'un président et d'un
exécutif dont le mandat sera limité
jusqu'à ce que le renouvellement général
des élus aient pu intervenir une fois
les élections hvl nouvel exécutif sera
mise en place le projet de loi
habilitera le gouvernement à prendre par
ordonnance les mesures nécessaires à
l'organisation du report de ce second
tour
celles ci concernent notamment les
modalités de financement des campagnes
de tenues de liste et d'autres questions
techniques relatives à l'organisation du
report du second tour
cet ensemble de mesures sera traduit
dans les textes qui seront déposés
immédiatement au parlement ainsi aux
côtés de l'état les collectivités
pourront jouer tout leur rôle dans les
jours qui viennent car nous avons besoin
d'elle et nous savons toute l'importance
des services publics essentiels qu'elle
administre pour nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi nous avons aussi veiller
à ce que leur continuité soit garanti
tout comme la continuité des services
publics qu'elle administre pourra être
assurée enfin le président de la
république a annoncé
toujours dans le même et unique objectif
de freiner la propagation du virus
des mesures concernant nos frontières
tout comme il est nécessaire de rester
chez soi les déplacements
transfrontaliers doivent être réduits
comme les autres au strict est
nécessaire minimum
pour réussir notre action ne peut
s'inscrire que dans le cadre d'une
réponse globale européenne
qu'il s'agisse des frontières
extérieures de l'europe ou des
frontières nationales au sein de l'union
européenne
c'est pourquoi ces derniers jours le
président de la république a échangé
avec ses homologues avec la présidente
de la commission européenne et le
président du conseil européen
j'étais en contact étroit avec mes
homologues des pays européens ainsi
qu'avec la commissaire aux affaires
intérieures ce matin même nous avions
avec la commission et les ministres de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne une
visioconférence pour harmoniser nos
actions permettez-moi de revenir sur ce
sujet également évoqué ce soir par le
président de la république
premièrement s'agissant des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne alors
que nous mettons tout en oeuvre au
niveau européen pour contenir la commune
a sion la contamination du coc vide 19
nous devons veiller à empêcher les
mouvements internationaux qui pourraient
renforcer la pandémie c'est la raison
pour laquelle la france appuie les
propositions présentées cet après-midi
même par la présidente de la commission
européenne les entrées de tous les
ressortissants étrangers dans l'espace
schengen sont proscrites
cela signifie que seuls les citoyens des
états membres de l'espace schengen et de
l'union européenne ainsi que les
ressortissants du royaume uni qui reste
soumis dans la période de transition du
braque site au droit européen pourront
entrer dans notre espace de circulation
commune les ressortissants des pays
tiers qui dispose d'un permis de séjour
européen pourront également continuer
d'accéder à l'espace européen
quelques autres exceptions seront
aménagés pour les personnels de santé
ressortissants des pays tiers par
exemple
par ailleurs je veux le souligner la
circulation entrantes et sortantes de
marchandises se poursuivra mais pour les
ressortissants de pays tiers qui n'ont
pas de raisons impératives de se rendre
en europe
alors ils feront l'objet d'une
interdiction d'entrée en limitant ainsi
les franchissement des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne
nous limiterons la propagation de la
pandémie cette décision que la france
prend en accord avec la commission
européenne
elle devra être prise de manière
identique et simultanée par l'ensemble
de nos partenaires européens
ce sera un véritable test pour l'europe
nous le devons aux citoyens européens
deuxièmement s'agissant des frontières
intérieures de l'union européenne
vous l'avez vu des mesures ont d'ores et
déjà été prises ces derniers jours pour
limiter les échanges que ce soit avec
l'italie l'allemagne air ou l'espagne
aujourd'hui
j'insiste il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
procéder à une fermeture totale des
frontières
il s'agit de limiter les échanges au
strict nécessaire
il ne faut plus de circulation
transfrontalière qui ne soit pas
indispensable
c'est cohérent avec les mesures de
confinement que nous prenons ainsi en
coordination avec mes homologues des
pays voisins
nous mettons en place des contrôles des
déplacements transfrontaliers non
nécessaire cela de part et d'autre de
nos frontières et en bonne coordination
avec les police aux frontières des pays
voisins
ceux qui n'auront pas vocation à
franchir ses frontières seront invités à
faire demi tour
en revanche je veux rassurer les
nombreux travailleurs transfrontaliers
sur la base de justificatifs de domicile
et d'emploi vous serez autorisé à
continuer de franchir les frontières que
vous franchissez quotidiennement et
c'est nécessaire de la même façon il est
hors de question de pénaliser le
transport de marchandises quel qu'il
soit l'approvisionnement de matériel de
soins ou encore en denrées alimentaires
ou de première nécessité ne sera donc
pas impactés par ces mesures
ce matin nous nous sommes entendus entre
ministres européens pour que ces mesures
soient bien proportionné dumont
concertée entre pays limitrophes et
notifiée à la commission européenne
mesdames et messieurs au début de cette
intervention j'ai employé les mots
combattre le cog
19 le président de la république l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est bien une guerre que
nous menons contre le virus
une guerre qui mobilise tous les
personnels soignants tous les agents de
nos services publics
toutes les forces de sécurité
intérieures de notre pays une guerre qui
doit mobiliser tous les citoyens
français dans cette guerre chacun a sa
responsabilité
chacun a les moyens d'anticiper et de
participer aux combats
cela n'a jamais été aussi simple en
réalité il suffit de rester chez soi
nous devons avoir ni panique ni légèreté
nous devons agir ensemble faire
république respecté les consignes les
gestes barrière rester chez soi
l'épidémie de comines 19 nous concerne
tous et cet ensemble et ensemble
seulement que nous pourront la surmonter
je vous remercie avec question bonjour
monsieur le ministre allison tassin pour
lci et tf1
plusieurs questions à l'issue de
l'intervention du président et de la
vôtre quels sont les métiers que vous
jugé indispensable hormis les métiers
sanitaire par exemple est-ce que les
postiers sont des métiers indispensables
et par ailleurs est-ce que les
transports vont continuer métro train du
ce d'abord ils sont très nombreux à les
métiers indispensables mais ce dont nous
parlons c'est pas de choisir les seuls
métiers pour lesquels les personnes
seront autorisées à se rendre à leur
travail la décision du président de la
république et du gouvernement permet à
tous les citoyens français de se rendre
à leur travail
quel que soit le travail est ce qu'il
est demandé c'est que chaque entreprise
ne prenne elle aussi sa responsabilité
d'organiser dans toute la mesure du
possible du télétravail de libérer au
fond les agents dont elle n'aurait pas
besoin à ce moment là et des
dispositions notamment en matière de
chômage partiel ont été évoqués ce qui
compte c'est aussi que dans chaque
entreprise en prennent le temps de là
ganisation de mise en place de ces
gestes barrières de ces comportements
derrière et l'organisation de l'espace
aussi donc pour répondre concrètement
votre question il n'est pas envisagé
d'interdire à tous les français de se
rendre au travail n'est pas envisagé non
plus d'interdire à tous les français qui
ne serait pas dans des fonctions
essentielles au bon fonctionnement de la
nation de se rendre au travail
les français peuvent se rendre au
travail mais doivent limiter au maximum
leurs déplacements
et s'ils peuvent par exemple user du
télétravail pour éviter de se rendre
dans l'entreprise cela doit être
favorisée à la fois par l'entreprise est
à la fois par le salarié pour les
transports dès lors que nous invitons
chacun à réduire au maximum l'usagé des
transports collectifs mais aussi des
transports individuels
il va de soi que des mesures de
diminution de l'offre de transport
accompagnement ce dispositif
par ailleurs une autre question sur les
municipales est-ce que ce report du
second tour signifie qu'il y à une
sanctuarisation des résultats du 1er
tour les résultats du premier tour sont
sanctuarisés la seule différence est que
le calendrier électoral aurait évolué
que avant demain soir 18 heures
l'ensemble des listes soit déposé pour
le second tour ce ne sera pas le cas et
nous déterminerons avec les partis
politiques lors de ce rendez-vous qui
est prévue sur la base du rapport
scientifique que nous aurons nîmes et le
moment exact pour le dépôt des
candidatures pour le second tour si le
second tour a lieu au mois de juin comme
nous l'envisagions dans ce cas là ce
sera quelques jours avant il nous
déterminons cela comme le veut l'usagé
de sélection vous avez fait également
mention d'une amende de 38 euros qui
pourrait passer à 135 euros
dans quelles conditions cet amant
augmenterez tel aujourd'hui pour toutes
les infractions
la vente dont nous disposons
juridiquement il 38 euros nous prendrons
très très vite
un décret qui doit être présenté en
conseil d'état pour porter la monte de
38 à 135 euros
c'est une question d'heures ou de jours
au maximum mais c'est le temps de du
formalisme nécessaire de consultation du
conseil d'état et quelles seront les
conditions pour cette sanction parce
qu'on voit de la question toute
infraction voir l'objet d'une sanction
je le dis clairement il ya des interdits
et je n'ai pas peur de ce mot il ya des
exceptions je les ai rappelés nous les
détaillerons il y aura très vite sur
l'ensemble de nos supports de
communication des questions réponses qui
permettront de répondre à des questions
est extrêmement pratique est ce que je
peux sortir mon chien une fois par jour
la réponse est oui mais rapidement dans
le cadre de l'accompagnement des besoins
naturels du chien et donc nous
répondrons précisément cela dans ce cas
là on remplit une petite fiche plomb
téléchargent et on a le droit de sortir
dans ce cadre là ceux qui enfreignent
ces règles pour en faire l'objet
effectivement d'une amende
concrètement ça va se passer comment
pour les policiers on a du mal à
s'imaginer comment ils vont pouvoir
faire la différence entre une personne
qui va faire son jogging et qui n'a pas
et une autre qui n'auraient pas le droit
de sortir sortirait du cadre légal
c'est assez simple la personne aura
imprimer une déclaration sur l'honneur
je fais confiance aux français pour
respecter les déclarations sur l'honneur
et ils seront contrôlés le plus
simplement du monde comme on peut l'être
pour un contrôle routier qui n'est pas
forcément celui que l'on a au moment
d'une infraction mais pour contrôler par
exemple alcoolémie d'un conducteur
il n'y a pas de présomption on arrête le
conducteur on contrôle le conducteur et
si effectivement il est en infraction
dresse une amende c'est exactement ce
qui se passera dans les transports
publics dans les transports privés
motorisés mais aussi pour les piétons
mais surtout je crois que l'on jeu c'est
celui de la responsabilité individuelle
notre objectif n'est pas de sanctionner
mais si nous devons sanctionnés nous le
ferons mais notre objectif est que
chacun prenne sa propre responsabilité
d'abord comme acteurs de la nation pour
faire république mais aussi comme
citoyen responsable
je ne doute pas de la conscience et de
la citoyenneté des français et du bon
ordre et du respect du bonheur mais si
ça n'était pas le cas j'ai évoqué la
mobilisation de 100 mille policiers
gendarmes qui contrôleront les rues qui
contrôleront les transports et qui
sanctionneront chaque fois que ce sera
nécessaire c'est à dire que concrètement
pour aller chercher une baguette de pain
à la boulangerie je devrais avoir monté
ces patients qui pourraient télécharger
décide demain midi ce document que vous
rédigerez vous même si vous êtes contre
lille fera l'objet d' ailleurs d'une
attestation de contrôle de la police ou
de la gendarmerie c'est vous êtes
contrôlés dans ce cas pas l'art une
dernière question on voit beaucoup de
familles qui se réunissent et qui
prennent femmes et enfants pour aller à
la campagne pour fuir les grandes villes
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
comportement est ce qu il est recommandé
nous recommander ce que vous dites aux
français fait le choix d'un domicile
d'ici demain midi parce que vous
pourriez rester peut-être un mois voire
plus mais je crois que l'essentiel des
français sont aussi dans des conditions
de travail je les ai bien dit nous ne
fermons pas l'économie nous fermons pas
les entreprises et donc celles et ceux
qui travaillent vont vouloir rester à
leur domicile quotidien pour continuer à
voir ses activités là donc je pense que
ne s'agit pas d'anticiper des mouvements
massifs certaines personnes peuvent
faire le choix ou commencé à le faire
pour le faire encore demain de se rendre
dans la résidence secondaire si l'on
remonte une mais je voudrais vous dire
que ce n'est pas l'essentiel des
français essentiel des français ont un
domicile et lui vivent dans ce domicile
et nous devons les accompagner dans ce
cadre là mais ce qui compte c'est
surtout de les protéger et ce dont on
parle c'est de la protection des
français
alain accords pour europe 1 est ce que
les militaires en plus de leurs
opérations de d'évacuation sanitaire
dont a parlé le président la république
seront amenés à eux aussi à participer
au contrôle les français dans la rue
non ce n'est pas leur fonction il
renforce
régulièrement ils appuient les forces de
sécurité intérieure vous le savez mais
ils n'ont pas vocation à procéder à des
contrôles
j'ai indiqué un chiffre de cent mille
policiers et gendarmes qui seront
mobilisés mais ce n'est pas pour mettre
en cause la qualité de l'engagement des
militaires qui sont très présents à nos
côtés au quotidien et qui seront aussi
le président de la république l'a dit
totalement engagé dans la gestion de la
pandémie et notamment dans des
transports sanitaires dans des renforts
sanitaires je pense aussi à tout le
corps médical de l'armée qui est
totalement engagé au moment où je vous
parle donc il ya des partenariats
naturel évident mais il n'y a pas de
mobilisation de l'armée pour contrôler
nos rues ça n'est pas le cas nos forces
de sécurité intérieures seront largement
déployée pour cela certains syndicats de
police dénoncent le manque de moyens
comparé notamment aux policiers italiens
par exemple qui sont équipés
systématiquement paraît-il de de masques
notamment à la frontière franco
italienne notent la dgpn il ya quelques
jours parle d'un kit simplement par un
kit de gel et de masques par véhicule de
police est ce que c'est suffisant
doctrine d'emploi des masques a été
définie non pas par le ministère de
l'intérieur m'a parlé par les
professionnels de santé
et c'est cette doctrine d'emploi que
nous appliquons pour les policiers pour
les gendarmes au moment où il serait en
contact avec une personne susceptible de
présenter le kobe 19 ou d'avoir le qi 19
et de se protéger
cette doctrine d'emploi qu'il faut
proposer et développer pour nos forces
de sécurité intérieure
mais nous devons respecter nous aussi le
protocole d'utilisation des masques tel
qu'il a été défini par le conseil
scientifique et nous devons accompagner
mais votre question me permet surtout de
souligner leur engagement les policiers
des gendarmes mais aussi des pompiers
qui sont totalement mobilisées au
quotidien pour le service des français
et qu'ils sont très engagés aussi dans
la lutte contre le coc vide 19
merci beaucoup
on
je vous
en fait un fichier